well apparently you are going to have to
get control of your spending and you are
going to have to live without debt
because god only knows where your
government is going to be when you hit
retirement how do they face down a
spending problem they just say well
let's just wait another year and let's
go further into debt while we're waiting
and I guess the you know oh man
the Republicans I just said the best way
they can beat the Democrats is to
surrender that's what they did they just
said well we're going to we want
Obamacare we want to be able to gripe
about Obamacare and them not to be able
to gripe about us standing up for
overspending and so we're going to just
let we're going to let you have what you
want you can spend whatever you want and
you can go as far and debt as you want
I'm just aghast of the idiocy in
Washington on both sides of the aisle
you you people are just you are
unbelievable you are unbelievable it
just makes no sense whatsoever and it's
not even a political discussion it's
economic discussion and we're just going
to so we just the the quote-unquote I
can't even use the word leader in the
same sentence with these people on these
people in Washington that you have
elected voted to continue to go as far
in debt as the current administration
wants to go for another year no holds
barred just whatever the flip you want
to have a spoiled teenager spending
out-of-control spending called the
government and what are we going to do
oil is just do more of it it's working
so well all day the stock market went up
you know why the stock market went up I
can help you with that the stock market
likes predictability even if it's stupid
a predict
stupid is better for the stock market
than an unpredictable smart and this is
a predictable stupid
anyone with sixth-grade math skills
knows that this is a predictable stupid
so we're 17 trillion dollars in debt
going up up almost 18 up almost 19 look
up it'll be by the time you say it
almost they can't hit another trillion
and these guys just go ahead and pass it
just like nothing and the truthfully I
mean it's a political strategy on the
part of a handful of Republicans to be
able to gripe more about Obamacare and
not be griped at about having stood up
to the overspending in the government
give them whatever they want let them
let them give enough rope they'll hang
themselves now they're hanging us
they're not hanging themselves they're
hanging us you and I we the people are
getting hung out to dry with this mess
you people are disgusting you people in
Washington supposed leaders jeez you're
disgusting
you're just disgusting you're disgusting
you're awful you self-serving bunch of
ninnies unbelievable you're worried
about one thing your own little butt
getting reelected it's all you're
worried about just disgusting ah ah
you're in for some real leadership
you're in for it and even those of you
that call yourselves flamin crazy
liberals I mean I'm a flamin crazy
conservative in your mind I'm sure I'm
really not I'm probably more of a
moderate but on financial issues I'm a
extreme fanatic no question about that
but I mean even if you call yourselves
that you can't say this as wise and we
not with a straight face are you if you
got your head stuck so far up your
politics you think that just spending
into oblivion is continuing to do so is
wise and if you know if you're a
moderate Republican which is who voted
these things in
to look at these guys in the face and go
the way the best strategy you can come
up politically to beat someone is to is
to surrender to them and let them have
their own rope let them go make a mess
that's your best strategy you're a bunch
of wusses
you're just wisss that's all you are
just freakin cowards unbelievable man it
just is disgusting okay I had to get
that out of my system because I hadn't
had depended on the microphone a day or
two and I'm watching all this stuff and
I made the mistake of turning on CNN and
made the mistake of turning on Fox News
and seeing all this stuff and watching
and then and then I then I pull up the
website I'm just like a block watching a
train wreck
you know there's bodies everywhere body
parts laying around blood and guts and
you just you can't you're drawn like a
moth to the flame you know you just have
to see all the carnage that Washington
is unleashing in your grandchildren's
lives and it's just frickin carnage
that's all it is it's just nuts just
nuts just disgusting
you